welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Thor love and thunder or as I
like to call it Thor for war war or more
core just drop some major plot details
the guardians of the galaxy are
confirmed to be crossing over with Thor
in this next film which is all painting
a very interesting picture combined with
the details about Christian Bale
confirmed as the Thor villain wow this
may not be officially called the as
guardians of the galaxy the hype remains
real and now I'm gonna break down all
the new things we now know about Thor 4
spoiler warning in case you suck and
thanks to privacy icon for sponsoring
this episode
you sign up now at privacy comm slash
new rock stars you can get $5 today they
used on any purchase online recently Vin
Diesel pulled over from living his life
a quarter mile at a time to talk about
doing the voice of Groot in the Marvel
films and dropped this interesting gem
about the guardians of the galaxy
appearing in the next Thor no Thor will
also the director talked to me about how
Thor will incorporate some of the
guardians of the galaxy which would be
very interesting nobody knows but maybe
I shouldn't have said anything
you throw us a bone really is all about
family to you this reveal confirms the
always intended plan after Avengers
endgame which ended with Thor joining
the guardians of the galaxy and
humorously feuding with Peter quill
Luber who was the captain now originally
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 was going
to come out before Thor for probably an
intended release date of May 2020 when
Black Widow is now coming out but then
all that dumb drama and Summer 2018 led
to director James Gunn being temporarily
fired from Guardians 3 delaying that
film and even worse delay nerdy YouTube
channels from having more to break down
and hash tag actors accidentally leaving
their Instagram posts after in game came
out Gunn broke his social media silence
to confirm that guardians 3 would not be
titled as guardians of the galaxy but
that doesn't rule out a crossover and
when Marvel announced its phase 4 lineup
shortly after guardians vol 3 was
nowhere in sight delayed to 2022 were
beyond sometime after James Gunn wraps
his Suicide Squad sequel for DC coming
August 2021 but one exciting mystery
lingering on that base for horizon was
Thor 4 titled Thor Levin Thunder with
the now oscar-winning Taika Waititi
returning to write and direct ytt cited
the Jason Aaron comic storyline the
Mighty Thor which leads to Jane Foster
wielding Mjolnir as Lady Thor suffering
from cancer
powering up in Thor motive in reverting
and resetting her chemo it's some real
Christian Bale was announced to be
playing a supporting role later reported
to be alien in otherworldly and recently
Valkyrie actors has a Thompson straight
up revealed that Bale would be playing
the movies villain some familiar faces
some new people into the mix Christian
Belle's gonna play our villain which is
gonna be fantastic fantastic Todd
Thompson you must watch your phrasing
around us nerds Christian Bale as an
alien otherworldly villain in a plot
inspired by the Jason Aaron conic run
yeah we're almost certainly guests
humming them down to gore the god
butcher from Jason Aaron's got a thunder
in original sin storylines they precede
the Mighty Thor gore swore to rid the
universe of all deities after these
false gods abandoned his family and
their time of need
years later the mere thoughts of gore
being right causes Thor to drop the
hammer and walk away
leading to Jane Foster later picking it
up some have also been pushing for Bale
to be cast as beta ray bill but as we
saw from that Sekar statue of Bill he's
at korbinite with a horse face and you
do not cast a face as iconic as
Christian Bale's for his voice along
with Rick I mean but Vin Diesel
confirming a Thor Guardians crossover
opens up other options for bales villain
and the way love and thunder story could
go look keeping up with content these
days it's tough because now we have to
get it all from these subscription
services about you but rather than stay
subscribed to like 10 things at all
times I like to only pay for the content
I'm actually consuming at any given
moment and the trick is managing the
credit card numbers that you give these
folks so they can turn it off and turn
it back on whenever you need it well
thanks to privacy icon for sponsoring
this video
privacy lets you make online purchases
using virtual burner cards for each kind
of purchase instead of your real card
for everything this protects your
identity and bank information on the
internet and lets you control the limits
on each virtual card so for example I've
set up an account with privacy I've
linked my bank account and I created a
card specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payments privacy will ding
you with lightning-fast precision if
someone tries to charge a car twice or
if the charge exceeds the amount you set
for it ha nice try Netflix I already
finished I am NOT okay with this the
only coin I will toss is for more
witcher no vendor can overcharge beyond
the limit that you've set for it it's
simple it's fast it's really just one
click they also offer these different
plans there's a free one that lets you
create up to 12 cards a month but also a
pro plan
where you can get 36 cards a month and
1% cash back on purchases
Annie Tim's plan for small businesses
there's a privacy Chrome extension where
you can fill out all of your card info
to save time just one click and all your
details are instantly entered head to
privacy comm / new rockstars and sign up
for an account as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get 5 dollars to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only it's
free money just go to privacy calm / new
rockstars and sign up now Vin Diesel's
exact words were some of the guardians
of the galaxy so to me that sounds like
less of a full team cross over like an
infinity war then an assortment if some
of the characters are so skated with the
Guardian side of the galaxy and some
loose ends from the Guardians films
tying in to the love and thunder plot
one of those loose ends could be Adam
warlock the genetically perfect space
Jesus cocoon by Aisha to seek revenge
against the Guardians Adam would also
fit the bill of an alien otherworldly
villain to all these characters before
his Batman days Bale played the smooth
skinned perfectionist Patrick Bateman
and American Psycho paying him gold and
you got yourself a space Jesus but
another connection between the Thor in
the guardians corners of the cosmos are
the elders of the universe Benicio del
Toro as the collector 10 alerta Vaughn
and Jeff Goldblum as a Grand Master and
we gassed both elders are in rough shape
after some recent events the collector
was a reality stone projection and
infinity war but you know might be dead
or bubbles or something and the Grand
Master was at the mercies of the Sicari
and trash spoke so perhaps Bale could
swoop to their aid as their brother
field or the universe try crow
slanderous champion of the universe he's
a master of unarmed combat and seeks new
opportunities to defeat the greatest
fighters from across the galaxy so just
imagine bales screaming himself hoarse
as he calls that fat Thor for a
challenge and forces the god of thunder
to get back into shape Jake man your
amateur you're unbelievable man you're
unbelievable number of times you're
strolling around in the background but
which other guardians of galaxy are the
some that diesel referred to
well obviously Groot he was in that
conversation and diesel had an
interesting description for groots new
form I
I only have two words about that
character and it is alpha group so by
alpha groots he could be referring to
King Groot an alternate reality warlord
version of Groot who never met rocket or
joined the guardians it could also mean
the inclusion of groots home society the
florid colossi from Planet X who are
ruled over by the arbor masters or maybe
Diesel's just reminding the rock that
he's always doubtful but too many of the
guardians in the story gets a bit
crowded by familiar faces
I think Tessa Thompson was referring to
cameos by Groot and maybe Rocket while
the main story of love and thunder will
remain centered around Thor Valkyrie and
Jane as the new Mjolnir wielder after
Bale arrives as a villain who rattles
Thor to his core but not before the war
for more Korg scores which Guardians do
you want to cameo in Thor for be sure to
join our official discord server where
we theorize on all the stuff with our
inner circle of supporters access our
discord by becoming a patron of new rock
sirs today at patreon.com slash new
rockstars comment down below with your
thoughts follow me at EI vos follow new
rock stars and subscribed interactors
are everything Marvel thanks for
watching
[Music]